Bernie Mac, Thuy Trang, Sage Stallone - these
actors and more were sadly all taken from us
too soon. Keep watching to find out which
actors you may not have realized had died.
One of "The Original Kings of Comedy" next
to Cedric the Entertainer, D. L. Hughley,
and Steve Harvey, Bernie Mac built his hugely
successful career through a stand-up routine
heavily influenced by Richard Pryor. That
in and of itself isn't unusual but Mac used
that cornerstone to build a presence
and style that was uniquely his own.
"I never watched what somebody else does. It
does not matter. Bernie Mac gotta do his thing."
That hard work paid off in Hollywood
with a series of high-profile roles.
Many might recognize Mac as Ice Cube's neighbor,
Pastor Clever, in the movie "Friday." He'd go on
to star in "Charlie's Angels: Full Throttle,"
"Ocean's Eleven," "Transformers," and more,
and also headlined a sitcom, loosely based on his
own experiences, called 'The Bernie Mac Show'.
During the last years of his life, Mac
suffered from Sarcoidosis, which heavily
affected his lungs, and he succumbed to pneumonia
complications on August 9, 2008, at the age of 50.
Harold Ramis was 69 when he passed away from an
autoimmune disease in 2014, which in and of itself
might have come as a surprise to many of the
film fans who watched him in '80s classics
like "Stripes," "National Lampoon's Vacation,"
and "Ghostbusters." A talented director and
screenwriter as well as a frequent fixture in
some of the biggest comedy hits of the decade,
Ramis' behind-the-scenes talents helped bring
us "Groundhog Day" and "Caddyshack," among many
others; in fact, he jumped back and forth between
either side of the cameras throughout his career,
co-writing both of the "Ghostbusters" movies
as well as "Stripes." Although few fans knew
he was ill, Ramis struggled with the side effects
of his infection for years—he had to learn how to
walk all over again after contracting autoimmune
inflammatory vasculitis in 2010, and suffered a
relapse the following year. His final onscreen
appearance came in the 2009 comedy Year One.
A veteran of stage and screen who amassed
a distinguished career spanning decades,
Richard Harris notched arguably his
highest-profile role late in his career,
courtesy of the blockbuster "Harry Potter" film
franchise. In two of his final screen appearances,
Harris played Potter's beloved headmaster
Albus Dumbledore in the first two installments
of the blockbuster film franchise, "The
Sorcerer's Stone" and "The Chamber of Secrets."
Although he'll always be Dumbledore
to generations of Potter-loving fans,
outside of Hogwarts, Harris compiled multiple
careers' worth of impressive credits and honors.
He was an accomplished singer, actor, director,
writer, producer, and songwriter who won Grammy
and Golden Globe awards for his work on 15
different albums and more than 70 films,
including "Camelot," "The Guns of
Navarone," "Gulliver's Travels,"
"Patriot Games," "Unforgiven," "Gladiator,"
and "The Count of Monte Cristo."
After being diagnosed with Hodgkin's disease,
Harris died on October 25, 2002 at the age of 72.
Best known for playing the young Carol Anne
from the movie "Poltergeist," Heather O'Rourke
skyrocketed to instant fame as the sweet
young girl that terrified audiences after
being sucked into the television set. In fact,
she may have played the part a little too well:
although O'Rourke racked up an impressive list
of credits after her breakthrough performance
as Carol Anne, she remained tied to
the franchise in the public's mind,
and she was one of a very small
number of original cast members
that remained with the movie series until
its conclusion with 1988's "Poltergeist III."
If you've seen the final movie, you may notice
that Heather's cheeks appear very puffy—and
although audiences didn't know it at the time,
it was a reaction to the medication
she was taking for Crohn's disease,
with which she was misdiagnosed. Tragedy struck
on February 1, 1988, when Heather suffered from
cardiac arrest while undergoing a surgery for
a bowel obstruction at the tender age of 12.
Thuy Trang was best known for her work as the
original Yellow Ranger on "Mighty Morphin Power
Rangers," but unlike a lot of actors who start
out in genre TV, she seemed in no danger of being
typecast; in fact, she was developing what seemed
like a potentially promising career after leaving
the show. Trang jumped right into feature work,
landing roles in a pair of movies released in
1996: the dark drama "The Crow: City of Angels"
and the Leslie Neilsen comedy "Spy Hard."
Clearly, Trang had enough chops to tackle work
from a variety of genres, but sadly, she never
had a chance to fulfill that potential—she was
killed in a car accident at the age of 27 in 2001,
after the driver lost control of the
vehicle and it plunged over a guardrail
on California's Interstate 5. Emergency medical
personnel tried getting Trang to the hospital,
but she died in transit, the result
of massive internal injuries.
One of Hollywood's all-time ultimate 'That
Guy' actors, Taylor Negron compiled a truly
impressive list of classic screen credits
without ever becoming a household name.
Although he tended to be on screen for
no more than a few moments at a time,
Negron's deadpan delivery made him a
fan favorite among film aficionados of
the '80s—and a standout in pictures like "Fast
Times at Ridgemont High" and "Better Off Dead".
Later in his career, Negron made memorable
appearances on hit TV shows like "Seinfeld"
and "Friends", but as much fun as he could be
onscreen, he was even more interesting behind
the scenes. In addition to acting, Negron was an
acclaimed writer whose work included published
collections of short stories, as well as
a trained painter whose work was shown in
multiple galleries. He was only 57 when he died
in early 2015, after a battle with liver cancer.
After making a name for himself
as a professional wrestler,
"Rowdy" Roddy Piper branched out onto the
big screen, most notably through his starring
role in the 1988 cult classic "They Live".
Leading that cult John Carpenter classic,
Piper waged war against a covert alien invasion
and coined an unforgettable catchphrase.
"I have come here to chew bubble gum and
kick ass, and I'm all out of bubble gum."
Piper's bone-crunching work in that film helped
set the tone for a busy Hollywood career full
of B-movie roles and small-but-unforgettable
appearances on television shows like "It's Always
Sunny in Philadelphia." On the screen as well as
in the ring, Piper gave every performance his all,
frequently elevating otherwise
forgettable material and consistently
serving as the most memorable component
of whatever project he was appearing in.
He died in his sleep in 2015 after suffering a
pulmonary embolism that triggered a heart attack.
Critically maligned and pretty much
ignored at the box office, "Rocky V"
is indisputably the least loved film of Sylvester
Stallone's long-running boxing franchise.
Take a careful look under its cheesier
elements, however, and you can see the
outline of a truly affecting story about
a former heavyweight champ going broke,
losing his ability to box, and nearly
losing his relationship with his son.
To help tell the story, Stallone
brought in his own 14-year-old son,
Sage, to play the part of Robert
"Rocky Jr." Balboa in the film,
and the young Stallone's time on the set clearly
made a positive impression: after college,
Sage continued working in the industry in small,
low-key projects, carving out a career in his
own right apart from his blockbuster-leading
father. Unfortunately, Sage died on July 13,
2012, at the young age of 36 due to a heart
attack brought on by coronary artery disease.
Long before he founded an ill-fated
amusement park using the secrets of dino DNA,
Richard Attenborough was already an
accomplished and award-winning actor.
Attenborough starred alongside Steve McQueen in
"The Great Escape", released in the midst of a
busy period that included some of his most widely
seen work. He also won two consecutive Golden
Globe Awards in 1967 and 1968 for co-starring
in "The Sand Pebbles" and "Doctor Dolittle".
Needless to say, Attenborough's career contains
no shortage of highlights, and his work will no
doubt be familiar to classic film fans. Younger
filmgoers, however, have their own Attenborough
memories thanks to his appearance as John Hammond,
whose ambitions led to the creation of Jurassic
Park. That blockbuster made him famous to a whole
new generation, but it's just one short chapter
in a life of many great cinematic achievements
that ended on August 24, 2014 at the age of 90.
"Whatchoo talkin' 'bout Willis?"
Kids of the '70s and '80s and honestly
anyone who enjoys the classic sitcoms
of the era will immediately recognize the
immortal catchphrase Gary Coleman coined as
an adorable kid on the long-running
hit sitcom "Diff'rent Strokes."
Coleman's diminutive stature helped him continue
to play younger characters throughout much of
his career, and at the peak of his fame, he
landed a series of film and television roles.
Unfortunately, his youthful looks
and peak height of 4 feet 8 inches
were side effects of an autoimmune kidney disease,
combined with the medications he took
throughout his life to fight the condition.
Work in Hollywood became harder to come by after
"Strokes" left the airwaves, and behind the
scenes, he underwent frequent dialysis treatments,
and was forced to undergo two kidney transplants.
After a fall at his home, Coleman died on May 28,
2010 of an epidural hematoma at the age of 42.
Exactly where you remember esteemed actor
Edward Herrmann from depends on whether you
favor musicals, vampire movies, medical TV shows,
or fast-talking mother-daughter family dramas.
Herrmann is probably best recognized today for
his role as pompous but warm-hearted patriarch
Richard Gilmore in the series "Gilmore Girls."
Richard's dry sense of humor and quiet authority
contrasted with the quick wit and constant
banter that flew between his daughter Lorelai,
his granddaughter Rory and his wife
Emily, who was played by Kelly Bishop.
Offscreen, Herrmann and Bishop, both classically
trained and meticulous about their craft,
were especially close. Herrmann's wife Star, whom
he married in 1994, would joke that Bishop was
his other wife. In Herrmann's final moments, his
family invited Bishop to say goodbye with them.
Before his longest-running role in "Gilmore
Girls," Herrmann worked regularly on TV
and in movies. He was nominated for
an Emmy for playing a priest in the
medical drama "St. Elsewhere," and won
one for the legal series "The Practice."
He played Franklin D. Roosevelt in the 1982
adaptation of "Annie" — having previously
played the President for a miniseries and
TV movie in the late '70s. And in 1987,
he played a stepfather from literal Hell
in the vampire movie "The Lost Boys."
Herrmann died of brain cancer,
at age 71 on December 31,
2014. In the Netflix revival of
"Gilmore Girls," it was revealed
that Richard had also died, sparking
big changes for Emily in particular.
Deezer D was one of the foundational actors on
hit medical drama "ER." Born Dearon Thompson,
he played nurse Malik McGrath for the show's
entire 15-year run, appearing in 188 episodes.
As often happens in real hospitals as well
as fictional ones, "ER" typically focused
on its physicians and surgeons, not the nurses.
But Thompson was one of just a handful
of actors who appeared in every season,
and his episode count makes him the fifth
most prolific member of the large cast.
Outside of "ER," Thompson had a few small parts in
movies including the cult classic comedy "Romy and
Michele's High School Reunion" and appeared
in Vanilla Ice's video for "Cool as Ice."
He played one of the members of a fictional rap
group in the mockumentary movie "CB4" in 1993,
and also rapped for real. He released multiple
records, including the full-length album "Delayed,
But Not Denied" in 2008, and continued making
songs until his death. His final track,
"History Can't Be Stopped,"
was released posthumously.
Thompson started having heart issues around 2008,
telling RadarOnline the following year that he
had been suffering from recurrent pneumonia
and heart failure. It was discovered that
he had a leaking valve and expanded aorta,
which was addressed with surgery in 2009.
According to Deadline, he went on to have more
operations on his heart over the next 10 years
or so. Thompson died on January 7, 2021, at
the age of 55, of a suspected heart attack.
Kathryn Joosten was in her 50s when
she started working consistently in
notoriously youth-centric
Hollywood in the mid 1990s.
She'd started acting in 1980, after realizing
she was missing out on following her dreams.
Despite her late start, Joosten built a career
playing one-off but always memorable characters
in hit TV series. Her credits include "ER," "3rd
Rock From the Sun," "Seinfeld,'' "Roseanne,"
"The Nanny," "Frasier," "Buffy the Vampire
Slayer," and "The X Files," to name just a few.
Later she would add the likes of "Will &
Grace" and "Grey's Anatomy" to that list.
In short, name a hit show of the '90s and
'00s, and Joosten probably appeared in it.
Her most memorable guest appearance was as a
woman who refused treatment for kidney failure
in Season 1 of "Scrubs." The episode, "My Old
Lady," consistently ranks as a fan favorite,
thanks in no small part to Joosten's performance.
"Unfortunately we don't really have a choice."
"Actually I do have a choice."
"Certain things you never expect
to come out of a person's mouth."
"I think I'm ready to die."
In addition to those guest roles, Joosten
landed regular parts in two major series.
She played the steely secretary to
Martin Sheen's President Bartlet
in two seasons of "The West Wing," combining
her talents for fast-paced drama and comedy,
and nosy but occasionally helpful neighbor
Karen McCluskey in "Desperate Housewives."
Joosten was first treated for lung cancer
in 2001, the year "My Old Lady" aired.
She was undergoing treatment while making the
final season of "Desperate Housewives," which
was written into her character's arc.
McCluskey died in the series finale.
Joosten died two weeks after that episode
aired, on June 2, 2012, at the age of 72.
Hugh Dane's resume reads like a list of the top
sitcoms of the '90s and early '00s. He played two
different characters in "The Fresh Prince of
Bel-Air," appeared in an episode of "Martin,"
and multiple episodes of "Roc." He had small parts
in "Friends," "Sister, Sister," "Everybody Hates
Chris," and "New Girl." On the drama side, he
played a judge in an episode of "The West Wing."
He also appeared briefly in the comedy
movies "Little Fockers" and "Bridesmaids."
However, Dane will most likely be
remembered and missed for his role as Hank,
the permanently unimpressed
security guard in "The Office."
He appeared in 22 episodes of NBC's
hit mockumentary about the inner
workings and ridiculous shenanigans in
a Scranton, Pennsylvania paper company.
Dane died at the age of 75 on May 16, 2018.
After his death, his "The Office" co-star Rainn
Wilson described him as "one of the greats.
So kind, funny, talented." On January 1,
2021, NBC's streaming platform Peacock tweeted
a video of a cold open that never aired,
dedicated to Dane. It showed one of Jim's
most elaborate pranks on nemesis Dwight,
featuring Dane as Morpheus from "The Matrix."
"If the blue pill's not safe to
swallow, someone should tell us now!"
Kenny Baker originated one of the most beloved
characters in one of the most popular movie
franchises of all time — but you wouldn't
recognize him from that role out of costume.
Baker is most famous for playing R2-D2, the
brave and mischievous "Star Wars" droid.
He was born with Dwarfism, but it wasn't just
Baker's height that made him perfect for the role.
According to his New York Times
obituary, he was the only person
small enough to fit into the costume
who was also strong enough to move it.
It helped that Baker had been in entertainment
for years: He sang, danced, played instruments,
clowned, and ice skated in various touring
companies. As he told the Guardian -
"There are certain closeup movements
only I can do convincingly. It's
all about giving R2 a personality,
and CGI can never really do that."
In addition to R2, Baker played an Ewok
in "Return of the Jedi," alongside his
wife and fellow actor Eileen. But the
furry, violent inhabitants of the jungle
planet Endor were less fun to play than
to watch, thanks to the stuffy costumes.
It wasn't just that they were hot: The heads were
impossible to see out of when they steamed up.
The last time Baker played R2 was for "Revenge
of the Sith," although he served as a consultant
on "The Force Awakens." He also appeared
in many other movies and series, including
"Flash Gordon," "Time Bandits" and "Amadeus."
He died at the age of 81 on August 13, 2016.
If you're a millennial who grew up wishing you
could have an identical twin to swap lives with,
you probably remember Natasha Richardson
best for her role as the extremely cool
fashion designer mom in the Lindsay
Lohan-led remake of "The Parent Trap."
That was Richardson's most prominent screen
role, but she had a prestigious stage career.
It started with a touring version of "The
Seagull" which ended in London's West End,
with Richardson appearing opposite her mother,
renowned British actor Vanessa Redgrave.
TV fans may know Vanessa best for her
role as Dr. Erica Noughton in "Nip/Tuck,"
opposite her other daughter and Natasha's sister,
Joely Richardson. Joely should also be known to
fans from "The Parent Trap" era as Anita in the
1996 live-action adaptation of "101 Dalmatians."
As you've probably noted, Natasha
was part of an acting dynasty.
Her grandfather Sir Michael Redgrave,
Vanessa's father, was famous for tragedies.
Natasha's aunt, Lynn Redgrave, Vanessa's sister,
was an Oscar-nominated theater superstar. To
round out the family, Lynn and Vanessa's brother,
Corin Redgrave, was a stage actor and playwright.
Natasha met actor Liam Neeson
when they starred opposite each
other in a Broadway production of "Anna Christie."
She was nominated for a Tony for the role, and
the two later married and had two sons together.
Natasha died suddenly of head injuries
sustained during a skiing trip on March 18,
2009. She was 45.
In a show that made superstars
out of its six main cast members,
James Michael Tyler managed to hold his own
as one of the most memorable side characters.
He played coffee shop manager Gunther in
"Friends" for all 10 seasons, appearing in 150
episodes total, although he didn't have a line
for his first 33 appearances. Tyler originally
landed the role because he knew how to work the
fancy espresso machine on the Central Perk set.
Not one to take himself overly seriously,
after "Friends," he played himself in the
satire "Episodes," which saw that version
of Tyler experiencing a slightly awkward
reunion with Matt LeBlanc, who played
Joey on "Friends," also playing himself.
Tyler loved the experience of being in
"Friends," although there was one drawback.
As he told Digital Spy, he was cast with
very distinctive bleached blonde hair,
which added to his character's mystique. But
it was originally the result of an experiment
he let one of his friends perform, which
turned into weekly bleach jobs for 10 years.
Tyler was diagnosed with prostate cancer in 2018,
which he didn't make public until June 2021. That
month, he announced in an interview with NBC that
the cancer had reached stage four, meaning it
had spread to other parts of his body. He died
just a few months later, on October 24, 2021.
A veteran stage, film, and television actor,
Richard Griffiths is known by the masses for his
portrayal of Harry Potter's uncle, Vernon Dursley.
While Dursley was for the most part always cruel
to the young wizard, he was still a part of
Harry's family—and he ultimately helped prove that
the Boy Who Lived had a golden heart because he
still cared for the uncle who treated him poorly.
Outside of the "Harry Potter" series, Griffiths
won a slew of awards over the course of a busy
career, earning particular acclaim for
his portrayal of English teacher Douglas
Hector in a play called "The History Boys."
He also starred in a variety of projects,
including "Superman II," "Gandhi," "Sleepy
Hollow," "King Ralph," "Hugo," "Pirates of
the Caribbean: On Stranger Tides," and "The
Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy." Griffiths
passed away at 65 on March 28, 2013 due to
complications shortly after having heart surgery.
Brad Renfro skyrocketed to fame at
age 11 through his acclaimed work in
Joel Schumacher's adaptation of author
John Grisham's book "The Client."
High profile roles quickly followed, and Renfro
made appearances in "Sleepers" opposite Brad Pitt,
"The Informers" starring Kim Basinger, and
"Ghost World" alongside Scarlett Johansson.
Yet as his star continued to rise on screen,
Renfro faced a darker path behind the scenes,
one that would ultimately see him fulfilling the
sad destiny of many child actors, plunging into a
life of illegal drug use and trouble with the law.
After attempting to buy drugs from an undercover
L.A. police officer, Renfro pleaded no contest to
attempted possession of heroin and spent ten days
in jail. On January 15, 2008, at 25 years old,
Renfro's turbulent story reached a tragic end
when he was found dead of an accidental heroin and
morphine overdose in his apartment in Los Angeles.
Dana Plato played Kimberly Drummond in
the long-running hit television series
Diff'rent Strokes. Cast alongside fellow
child stars Gary Coleman and Todd Bridges,
she was catapulted to instant stardom. To
cope with the mounting pressures of fame,
Plato often indulged in cocaine and marijuana
off the set—yet it wasn't until she became
pregnant that the network released her from
her contract, helping her trigger a downward
spiral of drugs and alcohol that included work
in adult films and a spread in Playboy magazine.
She later moved to Las Vegas, where, desperate
for cash, she robbed a store for less than $200
and was bonded out of jail by Vegas entertainer
Wayne Newton. She died at the age of 34 on May 8,
1999, in her RV in Oklahoma after taking
a fatal dose of lortab and valium.
Best known for her work starring as Mel Gibson's
daughter in the blockbuster "The Patriot,"
Skye McCole Bartusiak was a child
actress with a promising future.
She made her film debut in "The Cider
House Rules" in 1999 and starred with
Michael Douglas and Brittany Murphy in
"Don't Say a Word" in 2001. She also
appeared in the film "Kill your Darlings" with
"True Blood" star Alexander Skarsgard in 2006.
Unfortunately, Bartusiak's life behind the
scenes wasn't as glamorous as fans might have
assumed—and included some dangerous drug habits
that would end up contributing to her having an
accidental overdose in 2014. According to
Bartusiak's mother, the young star had also
been suffering from epileptic seizures prior to
her passing, which led the family to initially
believe she'd choked to death before the
coroner's ruling made the tragic truth clear.
Before getting his big break, Michael K.
Williams was consistently cast as one-dimensional
criminals. He was a young Black man in a white
industry that didn't know how to tell diverse
stories about people who looked like him. Also,
he had a distinctive facial scar from the time
someone attacked him with a razor–something
else Hollywood didn't know what to do with.
Williams' big break came courtesy
of "The Wire" character Omar Little,
an armed robber who targets drug dealers,
and the most feared man in a territory
ruled by violence. But Little wasn't a
carbon copy of those previous characters.
For one thing, he was openly gay, in a homophobic
society that mocked gay men as weak. For another,
he was known to give some of his ill-gotten
gains to people in his much-in-need community.
After playing Omar, Williams landed
roles in several prestigious series,
including crime drama "The Night Of," "When
We Rise," about the gay civil rights movement,
and a recurring part as a racketeer in
Prohibition drama "Boardwalk Empire."
He even got to show off his comedy skills
in "Community." In 2019, he appeared in Ava
DuVernay's "When They See Us," as the father of
one of the wrongly accused Central Park Five.
In 2020, he was nominated for his fifth
Emmy for the HBO series "Lovecraft Country."
Williams died at the age
of 54 on September 6, 2021,
of what was later confirmed as a drug overdose.
If you or anyone you know is
struggling with addiction issues,
help is available. Visit the Substance Abuse
and Mental Health Services Administration
website or contact SAMHSA's National
Helpline at 1-800-662-HELP (4357).